jake paul
passes test tests with split decision
victory over tyrone woodley did anybody
see the fight here no i watched it i
watched it do you watch it yeah what'd
you think about it
were you impressed with him
uh no he wasn't you were not impressed
with them no not at all what do you
think
i think uh look tyron woodley's a is a
beast yeah so i think jake paul is uh by
the way do you think that was fixed any
of it yeah
i think he's fighting guys that are i
mean tyrone woodley's maybe five eight
jake paul's not a small dude no we saw
him yeah when we were leaving the party
that one night he's 6-1 legit
strong guy i mean his brother's an
absolute beast uh monster can we admit
that the matchups that we're seeing yeah
aren't like i mean exactly when he
fights a real boxer i think he's gonna
get his ass but for now but pat you
brought up a good point even though i
didn't watch it
he's in shape he's got one round he's
unable to move man yeah
that's no joke like if you've ever like
put gloves on harder
it is tough here's the thing here's my
perspective on why it was fixed tell us
first they didn't beat each other up
really yeah so the whole thing was eight
rounds i'll prove that i can box an
entire eight rounds and then i'll move
up because if jake paul loses then well
let me ask you there was one part that
was sus where woodley rocked them had
him up yeah literally on the road but
here's a question finish him off david
profile question for you have you seen
woodley's last five fights
no i'm not have you seen how woodley
fights i know he's a striker but now
have you ever seen this phrase you've
seen dana white's biggest frustration
with woodley's passes yeah he's not
aggressive he's passive so ty
dana white said this guy could be the
face of ufc okay but he's passive he
doesn't fight he plays like point game
that's how he wins fights that's not how
you sell out a crowd so nobody wants to
see the the guy be like that so he
typically fights like that that is his
strategy that's how he's fought but to
me
i've never said anything positive about
jake paul's uh boxing uh uh you know
abilities it's always the fact that
these guys are great at getting
attention they're fantastic at what
they're doing i was impressed the fact
that this guy could hang for eight
rounds you kidding me for 190 pound guy
six one to be able to last eight rounds
it was impressive jake paul lebron james
machine machine gun kelly baker mayfield
odell beck all of the most annoying
people in our zeitgeist are all centered
in one place cleveland ohio the mistake
by the malay
did a great show there last year there
was multiple people on the meet and
greet line that had teeth whittled down
to spikes and face tattoos
this is it's come we've come a long way
from drew carey cleveland ohio boy this
is the ohio system saying like you're
thinking about moving there oh man what
you're saying yeah you got a feeling he
likes that uh it it can't the the actual
uh the the
bay catches on fire by the way do you
know why it's called the mistake by the
malik cleveland because they spelt it
wrong there's an extra e that shouldn't
be there cleveland uh yeah so anyway
there's a little tasty tip there's the
value for your question how much longer
are people just gonna
tune in to this jake paul nonsense
as long as he wants like he wins but
nobody's nobody's watching to watch him
win people are watching to get his
watches out there is a community that's
supporting this but they're oh you're
sure they're supporting yeah i would say
80 of the people like most of the ufc
wants to see him get knocked out yeah
most and by the way woodley is the
better fighter yeah woodley just didn't
capitalize on the opportunity that he
had and secondly yeah if the referee
would have done his job right that's a
knock down yeah yeah he knocked them out
there so that's one nice so that needed
to be recorded but they didn't do it
that's extra point it would have been 10
8 rounds still wouldn't made a
difference two rounds one of the things
that he did right is
an old strategy from purnell whitaker
maybe no sugar ray
whitaker the last 10 seconds he knew how
to score points yeah jake went and
scored points the last 15-20 seconds
that's what he did he was behind it
and that's the last thing for the
referees not the referees the judges
remember is the last and you know but
woodley should have won the fight yeah
what happened after like so i saw a clip
tattoo yeah what's up with that he's the
king of the [ __ ] boys yeah i mean that's
that's his whole appeal you know jake
announced yesterday he retired oh i know
right
you usada
is
i think he's not going to do it to piss
him off i don't think jake's going to do
the rematch because i don't think
anybody cares to see those two fighters
no i agree i don't think he's going to
move on nothing they're going to move on
to someone else
fury little brother fury
oh tommy yeah i'm fury
that's uh flirting yeah i hear everybody
talking about that
but i mean the last name fury you do not
want a box with a guy with a last name
fury yeah
the the
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]